- Welcome back, everybody.
I can't tell you how awesome it is
to be here in my home studio.
Los Angeles is filled with
so many cool experiences.
In fact, there's a one of a kind
interactive installation in Santa Monica,
that promises to make you feel
like your absolute best self.
I'm talking about Tyra Banks
and her new business
venture, The Posing Party
at ModelLand.
Since I can't be in two places at once
I asked Danielle
Nottingham, the co-host of
California Live, to check it out for me.
And she's there now.
Hi.
(audience cheers)
- Hi, Kelly, and welcome to ModelLand.
This is an immersive, interactive show,
it has actors, it has models
and it's not just about striking a pose.
You are your own muse here
and there's no place like
this anywhere, Kelly.
- I love it.
So you're supposed to
get the VIP experience
so you have a tour guide, right?
- Oh, Kelly, I don't
have just a tour guide.
I have the tour guide, Tyra Banks.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] What's up, Tyra?
Wait, wait, tell us more about ModelLand.
- Yeah, so ModelLand is a place
that hosts so many different themes.
Our first theme is, The Posing Party,
where anybody and everybody can come.
All shapes, all sizes, all ages.
Families, mamas', daddies, dates.
Everybody can come and learn how to take
the most amazing pictures in the world.
If you have a camera phone,
you are your own muse.
So we wanna teach you how to get
the right angles.
Teach you lighting.
Teach you everything, but it's a show.
It's a theatrical show
and you are the star of the show.
So, you're being
entertained and enlightened,
at the same time.
- And Tyra, you've been
trying to open this
for a couple of years?
- I had this idea fifteen years ago.
- Oh wow, fifteen.
- Yes.
So let me break it down 'cause Kelly,
I know you are a dreamer, you had a dream
and you're living your dream now.
- Yeah.
- So, I had a dream to open this place.
I was like, immersive,
theater, retailtainment,
shopping when you're
like, being entertained.
People were like, huh?
What?
Fifteen years ago.
Then, maybe eight years
ago, I pulled that idea off
the shelves, pitched it again
and everybody's like
oh, yeah, entertainment
and immersive theater,
we know what that is now.
(group laughing)
- But now we're here, but then guess what?
I was going to launch it
and then guess what happened
to the whole world in 2020?
- COVID.
So we were never able to open these doors.
And finally, we are here.
I am so excited.
People have been coming and saying that
they've learned their angles.
Mamas', grand-mamas', everybody.
And it just touches my heart
because I've been studying poses since
I was fifteen years old and now
I have trained this whole place
to teach you all.
You guys will come to The Posing Party
and walk out divas and devos.
- It's magical.
It really is, magical.
- Thank you.
- I love it, wait, I love
that you had this dream
so long ago too and you stuck with it.
That's cool.
So can you give us a little taste
of the ModelLand experience?
- Oh, yes, so often when people
are wanting to take a photo.
When to try to fit in, what do we do?
We go, uh.
- Or like this.
- Trying to fit in, yes.
But what you don't realize is you have
to booty back, chest downwards.
- Booty back, chest?
- Yes, just a little bit.
Not too much, not too much.
- Why did nobody tell me this till' now?
- Chest downwards.
Yes and this is actually very flattering.
Particularly, if you have on a blazer.
Like see, if I'm like this.
(group laughing)
But if I go like this, do
you see the difference?
- Oh, okay, like this.
- This and like this.
It's booty back, chest forward.
Little things like that
you're going to learn here.
And that's just a little
tip of the iceberg honey,.
you got to come to The Posing Party.
- I'm just a little upset over here
'cause I'm forty years old
just now learning that trick.
I got such a big ole behind.
I was like, wait, what?
Now you're going to see me in every photo.
People are going to be like why is she?
Is there something wrong with her back?
What is she doing?
Yeah, no, I'm gonna use that.
- No, no, that booty.
- I love my booty.
- [Tyra] That booty being
thick and big and going-
- Oh, I love my booty.
- Like a wine glass on top of it.
- Yeah.
- And leaning up and do that, lean down.
- We need relating with booties.
You know I got a booty over here.
- Yes, you do.
- Thank you, Tyra.
- No, I love my booty.
But I'd like to look a
little smaller in pictures.
Tyra Banks and Danielle
Nottingham everybody.
(group cheering)
The Posing Party at ModelLand is open now.
So go online to secure your tickets.